la kooky Allah Cohen was late to work on
the night that his roommate disappeared
which is why he's still around to tell
what happened Outsiders called them all
homosexuals but the sex workers some who
lived his women all the time others who
dressed his women primarily on the job
call each other crazies as Alec Owens
reached opposite corner he could see his
friends were still there
he hesitated for a minute before
crossing the street and that's when he
realized the locos were not alone for
tall men and ski masks was throwing him
in the back of a green truck clubbing
them with the butts of their guns this
was the beginning of the civil war that
consumed El Salvador until 1992 the
United Nations NGOs journalists and
scholars have sought to uncover what
happens many of the more than 75,000 who
were killed or disappeared during the
conflict but no one has ever
investigated what happened to our
Collins friends there was his roommate
Christie whom he remembers as a gentle
26 year old who would bring him gifts of
coats or shoes from trips she'd
frequently take to Guatemala or Mexico
another was Veronica from San Bartolo
near the Honduran border who was so
pretty that her clients would sometimes
insist on having the pictures taken with
her Karolina was so well put together
that she'd sometimes get into trouble
she looked all woman out of Colin's head
and her clients would get violent when
they discovered she was trans as she
undressed Alec hone is one of the only
witnesses to their disappearances who is
still alive but the story of that night
is well remembered it's been passed down
from generation to generation of trans
sex workers in the country's capital
it's been retold so many times it can
sometimes be hard to separate fact from
legend passed down in the same way many
families retell the haunting mystery is
a still winger from the war Alec home
hid from the men rounding up his friends
that night by throwing himself to the
ground in a small garden he tried to
slink away after watching the men pile
his friends into the truck but more on
men were patrolling the surrounding
streets when the coast was clear he went
back to work on the corner within
minutes a client and common picked up
alcone figured he'd see Christie in a
day or two which is how long the cops
usually help sex workers after a routine
vice raid but Christie never came home
none of them dead Alec Owen went to the
police stations to try and find her even
hired a lawyer but the cops made fun of
him and hinted that his friends were
already dead El Salvador was 12 years
civil war at its roots and political
battles that have been going on for half
a century and in 1980 it blew up into
one of the last and bloodiest conflicts
of the Cold War bodies were being dumped
at a rate of more than 150 a week which
the US Embassy would tally and regular
violence Week in Review cables even as
the u.s. grew closer with the El
Salvadorian regime the death squads
victims were killed in the usual fashion
reported a cable from the u.s. embassy
of Washington kidnapped by a group of
armed men who appeared as civilians
taken away and he picked his pickup
trucks shot or strangled at both they
dumped along the roadsides but those who
lost their friends believed they died
because of politics the most intriguing
part of the legend of the disappearances
from the savior of the world and the
part that is probably the most
impossible to pin down is that they were
killed to cover up a government secret
they were taking that night the story
goes in a hunt for two sex workers who
had evidence of a crime evidence they'd
stolen from an American some of the
locals thought that America was a
diplomat while others believed he was a
reporter no one really knew why he was
in the country but they all knew what he
looked like he was a big spender who
always tried to at a time the two we
picked up shortly before the raid stole
his briefcase inside were some cameras
that the locals believed have been used
to photograph some kind of government
crime all of this might be easily
shrugged off as the kind of conspiracy
theory that proliferate some wartime
except several sources said they'd heard
it from people directly involved like
kooky IRA Cohen said the American came
to his bar offering a reward to get his
cameras back another sex worker who
asked not to be named said she'd been
warned that a hunt for the fees was
underway by a sergeant in the National
Guard who was a regular client several
told us that one of the thieves had a
wife a cisgender woman named Sonya who
lived in San Salvador for at least
another 30 years and was sometimes talk
about how the authorities eventually dug
to the briefcase out of her patio with
camera's still inside everyone believes
well thieves escaped but there are a lot
of different stories about what happened
to the ones who disappeared beneath the
savior of the world they're tortured by
having their fingernails pulled out and
their breasts shorn off or they were
dragged to death by horses at the
infantry barracks they're dumping a hole
on the road to the notorious mariana
prison the men said to have taken the
locals away wore no uniforms so there's
no way to be sure which force had taken
them
El Salvador is filled with stories like
these people turning a ghost because
unanswered questions are all that
remains of them and this story
particularly hangs over the trans sex
workers still trying to survive in San
Salvador
we're gang violence and random hate
crimes have claimed at least as many
lives as the war once did